the Latin patriarch of Jerusalem
Catholic Cardinal Pierre Batista pitala
he has just come out and offered himself
up to Hamas in exchange for Israeli
children who are being held
hostage this is what Cardinal pizzala
says I am ready for an exchange anything
if this can lead to freedom to bring the
children home no problem there is total
willingness on my part and he goes on he
says the first thing to do is to try to
win the release of the hostages
otherwise there will be no way of
stopping an escalation you want to talk
about true compassion and charity offer
yourself up compassion means to suffer
with somebody suffer with somebody offer
yourself up give of yourself totally
selflessly for someone else definition
of love to will the good of the other
for their own sake